[Music]
mike's with us in tampa hey mike welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you thank you for
taking my call i really appreciate it
sure what's up
i have been listening to you guys now
for about a month and i am absolutely
hooked i'm on a travel nursing
assignment here in miami so
i have nothing better to do with my free
time but listen to you guys my wife i'm
trying to get on board with everything
and the thought of us getting out of
debt is scaring her to death however
with that being said
um last year we sold our home and we
were able to profit around sixty
thousand dollars on the sale of the home
we spent ten thousand on some debt and
we have fifty thousand dollars
sitting in our savings account
hopefully ready to put a down payment on
another home we have a friend of ours a
mutual friend of ours that is
trying to convince us and i'm not for or
against it i just don't know i'm very
neutral on it trying to convince us to
move that fifty thousand dollars out of
our
okay as soon as we can
and put it into precious levels to
protect
or lose but to protect it from anyone
that might be trying to come in and
steal it from us if you will from our
checking savings account
what do you got to be kidding me
this guy's a conspiracy theorist from
now on isn't he like sounds like my
friends
just kidding again again i don't know
very neutral i don't know enough about
that
he's gone down he's gone down the rabbit
hole with alice in wonderland i mean
there's just the chances of somebody
stealing your fifty thousand dollars out
of a checking account out of a bank in
the united states of america is very
close to zero
that's absurd okay that's crazy that's
crazy talk
i mean and the chances of you losing
your butt putting this into precious
metals is very high
it's a good chance you're gonna lose
your butt and so really really bad
advice any other advice this guy gives
you don't take it either because he's
got he's really bad at advice
so are you are you talking about buying
a home here in the u.s you're u.s
citizens or what i'm hearing the accent
uh yes uh um i'm a green card holder i'm
of course eligible to to purchase a home
um
but um yeah we have a little bit of debt
that we
we need to pay off cars and um 401k
loans and such but um we were wondering
should we
um you know save the fifty thousand
dollars to put down on the home before
we
get out of our vehicles and stuff like
that or do we should we take the 50 000
and put that on our vehicles and then
try to cash flow on the home or just
again how much debt do you have
um
so i would say probably 60 probably 70
000 and what's your household income
um about
it's difficult to say right now but
probably this year i'm probably
scheduled to make about
120 great okay what we would tell you to
do is to become debt-free as soon as
possible build an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses and then
build up your down payment which will be
fairly easy to do when you don't have
any payments anymore
so no precious metals under any
circumstances yes pay off debt
become debt free it is the shortest
distance between where you are in
becoming wealthy
appreciate you listening mike don't
listen to this guy anymore he's not
smart